welcome back to 8701
in this video we talk about nuclear
binding energies
but before we get started on this topic
i would like you
to have a look at this table or this
diagram which shows nuclear abundances
in our
solar system so how many atoms of the
various types are
present in our solar system and you see
this super interesting
structure most of it is is hydrogen here
but and then there seems to be some sort
of an excess of iron
um and you know the stable goes all the
way to let
and beyond there's a little bit of a gap
here
so how is this possible how did this
particle get there in the first place
uh why is there some which are more
frequent than others
you know a very interesting question
which we will be able to answer at the
end of the discussion of nuclear physics
and the first starting point is to
understand why
nuclei are stable in the first place
what holds them together
and that's the discussion of binding
energies
so we can just very simply write the
binding energy
down we just you know sum up all the
ingredients
the number of protons and electrons
times z the number of
neutrons aim the mass number minus z
and then we subtract from this the mass
of the nuclei itself
what remains is the binding energy
just for record the mass of the proton
the mass of the proton the mass of the
neutron you see that the neutron
is slightly heavier than the proton and
the neutron itself
decays into the proton a free proton
does not decay
however inside the nucleus the proton
can also decay
and then we have the mass of the
electron you see there's a factor of
almost 2000 between the mass scales of
an electron and the mass of the neutron
so for all practical purposes we can
ignore this but if it comes to precision
measurements
then the mass of the neutron which is
half in mav
becomes a of an electron which is half
an mav becomes relevant
this plot here shows the average binding
energy per nuclei
as a function of the mass number and you
see that with the exception of those
light elements you see that this is
fairly stable
and in the range of 7.5 to 9 mev
you also see that there seem to be a
maximum around iron
um which then leads to you know an
advantage
in gaining energy when you or
gaining energy going to lower energy
state when you go in this direction and
in this direction
this part is called this part is called
fission this part is called fusion both
processes because we go to a
more energy preferred state are possible
and they're you know
they they can be used in order to attain
energy from nuclear processes
this diagram here can be parameterized
um and the rest of this video will talk
about
a very you know popular parametrization
of the binding energy
so this is semi-empirical um it's
called the white sector formula because
it was proposed by a german called
whiteseeker
sometimes it's called the semi empirical
mass formula
and sometimes the discussion is
summarized as a little liquid
drop model and you'll see why in a
second
what we see here is very similar to what
before we can calculate the mass
and from that the binding energy
by having those first elements here and
this part then here
is our binding energies and there's one
two three four
five terms which we're discussing now on
the next slide
which gives what this is shown here is a
parameterization
um so you can fix the data and get a
best estimate
um for the individual parameters in this
equation
all right so as the name said liquid
drop model
we can think about in some essence about
a nuclei nucle nucleolite
an atom as being built out of a
soup a liquid of protons and neutrons
which are bound together
so the first term which contributes to
the binding energy is the so-called
volume term
this dominates the binding energy and is
proportional to the number
the mass number remember the mass number
is proportional to the
third power of the radius hence
proportional to the volume
of the of the nuclei
and you know this contributes with about
16 mev per nucleon for proton and
neutron um from this we can conclude
that the nuclear force must be very
short range why is that
because in order for the binding energy
to depend dominantly on the volume
the individual nucleis can only see its
nearest neighbor
so this corresponds to a short-range
force
which is roughly of the distance of two
nuclei
if any given nuclei would be able to see
everybody else you would see a a term
quadratic in the in
in the in the number of nuclei and
available um as a result of this you can
calculate a central density
which is about 0.17 nucleons
per cubic fermi meters
or an average distance between protons
and neutrons
of 1.8 empty meters
okay so they're really tightly packed
the size of a proton is about
a femtometer
all right however
the proton the neutrons which are on the
surface of this
uh construct they see less
nuclear they see um less nuclear
nucleons around them
so if therefore the binding energy needs
to be reduced
and it needs to be reduced with the area
the area of of the surface of the of the
nucleus so it needs to be proportional
to r square
and therefore proportional to a the mass
number
to the two thirds okay
then the protons in the nucleus
they are electrically charged so they
want to get it apart
and that itself also reduces the binding
energy so this is proportional to the
number of charges squared
and then you normalize this by the
radius so charged square over
no normal charge square over r
so this is q square over r
all right there's two more terms which
are
quite interesting the first one is
sensitive to the asymmetry
between the number of neutrons and the
number of protons
and it can be explained by the pauli
exclusion principle
which allows only two identical fermions
neutrons or two protons to occupy the
same energy state so you basically fill
up the energy states
now as is shown in this picture here you
reach
a the lowest energy state if the number
of neutrons
and the number of protons is actually
the same you have higher energies if
there is
enough symmetry between those two
numbers so we have yet another term
which is sensitive to the asymmetry
between the number of neutrons and
protons
which reduces the binding energy
and last but not least the pairing term
which has
a very similar origin so what we're
looking at here is
you know the energy is lower if you have
an even number of neutrons
or protons it's higher and we have an
odd number so you can have an odd number
for the protons
or the neutrons in which case a is odd
and
the worst case or the the worst energy
state is achieved
having both the protons and the neutrons
um
hot so that's why this is a little bit
more complicated way to write this
you have the three different cases uh
number of protons number of neutrons
even
um a odd or both z and n
odd in which case a is even
just to add to the confusion a little
bit all right then you can make a
drawing
of the binding energy as a function of
the mass
and you see again those individual terms
the volume energy energy
the volume term your constant the volume
plus surface reduced
the volume plus surface column further
reduced and then all terms
put together here and you see again this
binding energy
parameterization which we just discussed
we saw the actual values
with the maximum maximum around here
for for iron